okay hi I have a very practical question
actually it's quite similar to the first
question you got and let me relate to
your example from your talk say that I
have an online book star I'm selling
books and making recommendations for my
customers and and I collect some data
let's say that this is like a basic data
collected same for every customer
nothing special nothing that I shouldn't
collect and statistics or sitting more
statistics or on for the person the
basic stuff nothing fancy let's say this
part is okay okay and say that you
didn't give me consent for profiling you
and I have my machine learning algorithm
that makes some kind of recommendations
for customers and now does this mean
that I should exclude you your data from
the algorithm so that it doesn't learn
on your data or maybe I could use your
data in the algorithm so it learns on
the data of all the customers but I
don't make predictions for you and I
don't give you the recommendations
because in the second case the algorithm
may be more efficient because I have
like more data so I would prefer if I
just didn't make the recommendations for
you but in the similar case as us in the
first question I will make your question
even more complex now because it may be
good for everybody
that not those who are privacy aware
drop out of your statistics or your
recommendation so the algorithm will be
biased in the non privacy people or way
of thinking way so we had something to
to optimize the ways in the street and
people who deactivated that Bluetooth
were not counted meaning those who are
poor they don't have Bluetooth those who
are privacy well don't activate neutrals
there perhaps or security people and so
where they lived
it wasn't counted so I think this is for
this
a public public service thing the public
service must not use such a thing which
may discriminate people even if they
don't know which which parts and they
cannot extrapolate because I don't know
the the reason behind I have a solution
for your thing this is in paragraph six
and there's your Article six that you
may use it for different and purposes if
the risk is mitigated and the there is
an existence of appropriate safeguards
which may include encryption or
pseudonym ization so it's clear that the
data you take cannot get back to me and
it really but count in your system this
may be alright but if you if you base
that on my consent
then you must not use this data so you
must you can only use like thinking of
you only want statistics from your
information but never never store then
in the other thing which formerly
algorithm I've bought this specific book
something like that but if it's
aggregated already then we are still
within all this data protection by
design things but the pseudonym ization
would be sufficient meaning also you
don't know anymore why is this
information part of your algorithm and
then I take your six paragraph four
thank you and it's in big exception it's
not totally clear how hard goes you have
to tell them if it's pseudonym as is
because it's person yes so but it can be
not an individual telling but the
general information and it's a calling
them to article 13 yep what is the next
topic or issues that data regulator are
planned to work or what it should work
by your opinion
so the directly the regulator's so a
privacy regulation will come next year
probably and this is more important now
than the GDP are probably because it's
everything with Internet not only data
not only personal data and it will also
at least in the planning affect the
developers as far as its browser or
other processing facilities it's not
only clear how far it goes but they're
working on that and I hope for a good
outcome and what about like machine
learning bias and fairness no no and
this is something where it's not totally
clear how much it should be regulated so
there will be work or the head started
on the Commission side already with 50
whatever people quite well the set of
many interesting people dealing with
that and there will be two things
happening in Germany as well with some
specialists and right now the first
proposals are made there should there be
an algorithm check also
what about should some some be built in
a specific way that they can be examined
more easily is it something where it's
totally free because there's no personal
data anyhow so or perhaps if it's a
public good thing then it does not
matter whether it's personal data or not
so if the bridge stability is is tested
it should work as well right and this is
happening as well and I think it's very
important and it's because the gdpr does
not say much about that and it addresses
specifically your crew okay thank you
very much for the talk I have a question
I'm interested in your position or a
data protection position in abstract
data if for example I have an unusual
name and it gets included into a data
model for example a company scrapes the
web since my my website and my unusual
name lands in a model and it pops up at
some point in some centers synthetical
data for example or in other contexts is
that protected in any way
if I do this as a company should I be
aware that I have to acknowledge all the
people with the names in my models so
for me I don't have a in Germany a
common first name but a common last name
in North Germany but even in my region
there are three mother dungeons and the
third one I know of the third one is
born on 24th of May I only found out
recently because of safe googling of
course meaning they they it's not a it's
not a company decision it's a personal
decision and so it can happen of course
so if a person was the same name as you
have always pops up because it's a model
person or another a real person you are
not protected because there's no not
your data but if it's linked to your
data because people assume you are the
the criminal one from the model for
example then you may suffer some some
risks or some some damages and this
means it depends probably on the the
model and how it will work if it's only
something where you have a very long
name and it's being tested how the
system works with long names then
probably it will never be published but
if it's something where you always your
personality is always bound together
with this artificial name it would have
been better for the company not to have
use it but if they are like with there's
also an its some some literature in an
investigation mystery your story or so
where I'm a detective or my not me
myself officer by my name is there and
I'm think I'm a good person I don't know
I haven't read that but sometimes this
is something where people think this is
the same person and the office have not
asked they have no check probably and
they don't know about people who get
born so this means I prefer something
where if it's not if I force in
synthetic sin soon for artificial data
and then it's better that it's clearly
not a real person so that you've put in
numbers within or so then it's totally
clear this is a made-up thing because
you never can exclude for the future
that there are others so even if they
look into all sources and try to be well
aware of what they are doing and of
course they will also mimic some
situations which may be linked them to
your real name but this means it's a
recommendation they did not do anything
wrong
because they never use your name you
they never said they mean you and there
might may be thousands of your name they
don't know and if it's Google almost
whatever
poets always together that then you have
the right to be forgotten because it's
not you but that it's clear that this
must not come for your name because it's
not you I wonder what is your opinion
about databases that we're designing a
way to not ever or to never delete data
and they have already PII data personal
identifiable information so it's very
costly to overwrite this data and the
data that is there can be used to
identify someone so what's your opinion
start at the beginning and if you design
the system so it's an archive system
then it's probably necessary and if
they're personal like we have something
for our governmental authorities and
it's always public and some people later
ten years later argue oh no I don't want
that to be public anymore but they've
not the right to destroy it it's in the
archive if it's a different legal
baseline but it's not not something
which is really embarrassing it's it was
public it's still public but if you set
up a system like we send emails an email
archive system of your company email
archive is not the same as an archive of
a state so some I think the Ducks or
some others demand that you have or your
company may demand that it's a totally
integer accurate a version like with
blockchain that each set of data is
linked to the others and you cannot
delete anything unless you rebuild
everything from scratch yeah but this
means you must not use such a system if
you know that you have to adhere to
rights a rectification correct
this might be possible or to deletion so
if it's a normal email thing there the
data protection by design would mean
there's not this kind of archive there
different kinds of blockchain by the way
that can manage that yeah but I wonder
for now on okay yeah well before the
positive if it's in blockchain is a very
good example I guess and it's already
very stored if you want to change it the
hope system doesn't exist anymore right
no but there are other types of block
chains that have a centralized for the
accounting system I totally agree that
it must not be manipulated right even if
it was a wrong accounting transaction
then this has to be corrected yes but
this would be a booking back feature
something like that but if it's
something like what's your name and you
are a criminal and this is now field
there and what what can you do then you
may need a new identity is this not the
cheaper solutions but so the the risk
has to be taken into account and even
twenty years before it was clear that
you should not use such a system for
something like we had something on that
were called write once read many also so
it's C D thing in the 90s and they
wanted the first he fires so not not
paper anymore and they put everything
there in the in the order when how they
came in the pages and we said in the 90s
you have to be able to delete those that
those pages that that are together in
the same fire and otherwise this means
of course if they are scattered on
several several of these warms then you
have to take all and rebuild the system
that was not as complicated as
blockchain ok and you have to make sure
that it this is that you know that this
thought may be necessary but depends on
the risk no excuses if it's if it's
somebody who only wants to challenge the
system it's no sense of a sensitive
information and there's no real risk but
somebody only wants to be
pain in the air sorry then probably he
would not but if it's a right and it's
really sensitive information then you
must not build the system in the right
kind of related to that specific to
blockchain I've heard that even if you
keep your data off the chain which is
what you're suggesting to have the
centralised part to have the data not on
the chain not probably I heard that the
public key of the individual's counts as
a personal data right so in that case
what do you do like whole Europe is not
supposed to use blockchain no no no but
I said the transactions is a good thing
with archives it's a good thing but what
are the things where you may be where it
may be necessary
that data is removed at least what
they've left for the future if this is
something with because the the it's some
something where it never should have
been on the blockchain but but it could
not be prevented or so so this is this
state secret I'm pretty sure that for
the state secrets a full thing would be
different but for transactions so the
financial transactions where it was
original for archives I don't see the
point and because Hale state oh yeah
then we really have to make sure that if
it's an identifier that for our example
this then the identity change of the
other side may be the simpler solution
so who decides that this is your
identifier in fact we have a system for
a passport refugees passport passport
things where they voted for us it's a
right now it's only a demonstrator they
voted for different identities for
different not only people but also in
different situations and this means that
the identity change is so easy it's not
your name there it's I think it's only a
hash of some value and the value can be
changed and so then you have another
point of solving that it's but it's not
as simple so this is another thing that
you can use blockchain but it has to be
clear that even those personal data then
can be skipped or con can be uncut or
unlinked
the next question you mentioned that
only the data needed for the business
model has to be stored and not more
before yeah for the purpose it is yep
who decides what's needed because let's
say I have a personalized recommendation
citizen one side of the spectrum is that
I use your IP address that I know right
now I don't even have to store it and I
can already personalize my website for
you the other side is that I can
convince people that I need everything
about you to have a recommendation who
decides what's the line there so this is
again something which is an old question
several decades decades old meaning the
person who sets up the system argues of
the controller this is we think this is
necessary and this makes sense and then
the person may send a complaint saying
no I don't believe that see you don't
need this information and then you say
no we thought we thought of your purpose
of your issue but you see we need it
because and so if you can really argue
that it's necessary then it is probably
necessary there might be the cards to
the judges to say you know you may have
this information this documentation but
of course the question is how much may
you couple for your purpose is the
purpose now something you can use and I
only serve those who disclose everything
so I need your shoe size for in my bank
because there's a different model if you
have very large feet or so then then it
may make sense on the objective way but
the coupling may not be allowed but this
is something about expectations and
about perhaps other kinds of shitstorms
who may suffer I think you mentioned
something like if a company does
profiling on you it needs to explain in
a way how they do it maybe so the sofa
yeah
suppose the one who won the court case
that they must they did not need to but
it was about on the formal system with
our federal Data Protection Act they
argued as a trade secret and they were
not obliged to give out the algorithms
or the much more information
on the logic so they did not comply to
what people read now from the GDP our
text so many people say the GDP are now
demands they have to disclose more but
the wording is the same or very similar
in the old version so this will probably
be the next court ruling but it's not a
European thing where probably they will
go to the European Court of Justice they
did not before and they probably are
trying to get very good cases where it's
more but it's easier for the judges
we'll see but at least for right now so
the the court ruling is five years old
or so right now I think the judges have
understood that the algorithms are much
more important and now the question is
it has to probably have to be disclosed
but to whom is it really necessary that
the person gets this information or is
it only for the risk treatment and then
there might be other like the
Supervisory authorities who get
information but this is so abstract on
the GDP our perspective the Federal Data
Protection Act has a little bit more
specialties there like that your well
your location of living may not be the
most important factor something like
that so it's I think only in Germany but
and also that there should be a metal
mathematics statistics
report auditing your algorithm that it's
kind of interim possibility to prove
that it's okay but it's whenever you do
prediction how to prove that it's really
necessary it's an open question because
we even if we get those reports how to
judge necessity is easier than
algorithms thanks for your talk one
question I have a very small online shop
and I try to be very lean on data so I
do store tracking data but it's not
related to to any identifiable people I
just want to see how they're using the
website also I start transaction data of
course but now maybe after you talk I
have to change something because I
you should keep the invoices but not the
actual transactions what solve course I
can't say hey my my idea on that but
probably you should talk to your
regulator and that's probably not me so
let's let's say it's not some place
because it's a I take care of these
things yeah and now are there any
additional steps I have to do like
documentation uh-huh or I would be
interested in that
yes documentation there's more question
like document risk okay so first of all
article 30 is you have to document all
your processing but it's very very few
information you have to document you
should have a security concept and this
should take or take out all the risk if
it's not specific on sensitive data
and/or political sexual America whatever
then you probably don't need a data
protection impact this is assessment but
perhaps on if you're a high ring perhaps
people who claim no you're not hiring
okay um there might be something where
people tell you more and how to deal
with the data and but probably your
documentation effort is what you want to
know about yourself anyway also where's
your data what about the contracts with
your processors are there any probably
yes for me you don't do everything on
your own do they behave according to the
DDP are and then they should give you
the information you will also document
no and only your if you you need if
you're from Germany you may need a data
protection officer then this has to be
announced and the announcement also if
there's a data breach but not your
documentation but if somebody if the
regulator asks you have to provide it
and if people ask not for your
documentation but for access right to
access then you should answer with the
environment Thanks and look at our
website and and the others so thank you
for a great presentation to be honest I
don't have any questions myself I'm just
here to learn from questions of others
then I have a question for now okay well
that's very good because actually I have
two questions
oh so the first thing was a bit related
to the shofar thing because I mean at
the moment they're not required to
disclose their model and they're not
required to say okay we're deciding
based on the fact that you didn't pay
something back five years ago and so on
but what if for instance let's say I'm a
financial institution and I want to
decide if somebody if I should give a
credit to somebody or not and if I want
to predict if they're gonna pay it back
or not but I don't I might not even know
myself what exactly based on what time
exactly deciding because I'm using a
black box model does that work under
mm-hmm
that's that's one of the questions also
with machine learning is it possible
that the machines learn and nobody knows
nobody really nobody knows what is
happening and it cannot be document it
only that you can challenge the system
and then there's output and it seems
okay but it's the prediction and what
about prediction can prediction be
checked really or doesn't probably it
influences the the future and usually
you cannot like the there were a few
cases here that you really try to have
both solutions but if it's one life do
you get the hip or not do you get this
can you become pilot or not that will
influence your life of obviously so it's
not decided
some people argue it's not possible to
have machine learning according to the
GDP our own personal data with automatic
decisions if it cannot it cannot be
documented or not challenged so it might
be something that is running in parallel
to some other process for some years and
then we will see that it may be even
first better than the many human beings
and then everybody will learn from that
but otherwise it may be creepy perhaps
the first few years it may be okay and
some and some other day I saw a CMOS
rules will whatever be violated and the
second thing was because animation and
this I feel it's something that
everybody does a bit different and is
there any I don't know
[Music]
common I don't know what to call them
that's rules baby
maybe but body of research or directives
or recommendations that you do on how
this would be properly done or is this
even check that this is properly done or
no no it's it's very difficult to do it
properly and the tsardom ization
definition is laid down in article four
number five and I wrote thirty pages on
that also and because it's so difficult
it's a very high well high highly
required thing that you must not get to
the identity only was a pseudonym I'd
ace the data only with additional
information and we will with Anissa
there will be something in October I
think and will the public consultation
on pseudonym ization among others and
data protection by default and there is
already something from the article 29
working party on anonymization
technologies three years four years ago
and this is quite good although they
could not use already the real
definitions here but it's still
something we can learn from which can be
of course hash values with not a limited
alphabet so what's f pseudonym ization
with telephone numbers is limited
alphabet does not work or if they're
aggregation inside or if there are
trustees which really make sure that the
data is not available because I really
have to run to the Train then okay so
you mentioned that there are still a
bunch of things about the GTR that are
being worked out sort of in practice and
I'm wondering if there are any that are
particular risks to sort of to your
understanding of the spirit of the GTR
are there still some things that might
happen that might undermine the main
idea it's really something happening
right now that what I told you that it's
the consent contract and legitimate
interest and the very big companies
argue everything is legitimate interest
and then people who try to say
I have an overriding interest so you
must not use my data for that and they
say oh it's a complicated question they
say it takes now not one month but three
months and probably it will work like
then you may not get the service anymore
and this would really change the system
as such and 90% of those companies are
residing in Ireland and Ireland this
what I know there is they are quite
proud that those companies said oh we
change this bit and now it's better and
so yes you did it or no we have a very
good but it's not a real solution and
it's not about data minimization it's
not about real consent it's not about
information so they are right now
undermining that these are the very big
ones and then we don't have any level
playing fields and this this is I think
now the very risky thing it what is
happening now there will be this
European data protection board and
people meet there from all the data
protection European countries and they
have to agree and now while I won't call
it fight but in fact it's it has to be
the argumentation what is now really
meant by that because some parts are
very fuzzy and then the rest probably
then it's really if you can always say
legitimate interest then it's nice that
you don't have to do anything anymore
only to write it down or the other thing
is contract because if legitimate
interests are accepted as a rule then
the overriding interests also have to be
accepted that can be argued but with
contract and if coupling is allowed as
much as Paul and as you want as
everybody wants as a big companies want
then and why should you be worse get get
less than the big companies the big
companies can argue this is part of our
contract then and it's not challenged
anymore then this is a new reality
you you sign if you want something you
have to sign that the bank is allowed to
use that but it's really an unusual
system that there's a processor that is
so mighty that's so powerful and it's
not rec not directly regulated by the
state this is because credit but it's a
different or European state or the US
and from what I know from so far they
are not the worst thank you so much for
your questions and and you're working on
a very important topic and all the data
protection regulates there so little
insight into what your questions are and
we need to bridge that and so I think we
need to meet again thank you very much